well sadly as we learn more about the
lead up to this horrible mass shooting
another one yeah not the one in texas
not the one we're now up to the one in
highland park illinois as we learn more
about it and we learn more about the
shooter
we learn
that yet another one of these often
repeated phrases from the more guns in
more places american right wing
is uh meaningless it is worth absolutely
nothing to us
we have now learned that the shooter
legally bought the guns used in the mass
shooting
after
becoming known to police and police
taking a number of knives from the
eventual shooter
the right loves to say listen we can't
take rights away but if there are
specific people
known to police
believed to be dangerous we need some
kind of system to prevent them from
getting guns but we can't take away too
many rights either and we don't we
shouldn't do anything about guns in
general well we had that here and yet
still able to legally buy firearms let's
get into the new york times article that
explains this highland park suspect was
known to police bought guns legally the
man accused of killing seven and
wounding dozens of others in a shooting
that terrorized the fourth of july
parade had been investigated by the
local police before
officers had responded in 2019 after
someone reported that he had tried to
kill himself and they came to his home a
few months later seizing a knife
collection after a family member
reported he had pledged to quote kill
everyone
they they knew about him
still in the years since the man was
able to legally buy several guns in
illinois including a high-powered rifle
that officials said was used in the
attack on monday
tuesday he was charged with seven counts
of first-degree murder
the details of the prior police visits
raised questions about whether the
illinois authorities missed
opportunities to use their relatively
strict firearms laws to block his gun
purchases and about whether a newly
newly signed federal gun law might have
made a difference
had it been in force earlier in a
statement the illinois state police
defended the decision to grant him a
permit to own a gun which he applied for
in december 2019. the police said he
appeared to have prepared for weeks to
attack the parade on monday morning had
used a fire escape to climb atop a
downtown business to fire dozens of
rounds from a high-powered rifle into
the crowd he escaped by discarding his
rifle blending into the crowd wearing
women's clothing
um
eventually they they got him as we all
know
so you know again we can go back and
forth this is just it's a circular
firing squad and it's almost you know
weird to use the term firing squad
proverbially when we're talking about a
literal mass shooting here but
we engage in the same pointless circles
here in the united states with this
stuff
well people need their rights
but in some cases we might be okay
slightly restricting if only on a
temporary basis after some kind of
investigation even though it's kind of
denying people due process
to limit people's ability to legally get
firearms
um
but do we actually enforce those laws
well not really and then joe biden wants
to do something and so do democrats and
republicans don't want to take away
rights but they're willing to do it but
the bill barely does anything anyway but
had it been enforced maybe it would have
prevented
we need a systemic re we need a rewrite
this would be like if you have a script
for a film and one person says they want
to tweak a little bit of the dialogue
and eventually you come to realize we've
got to throw it out and rebuild this
thing from the ground up
when other countries look at the united
states and i know the right-wingers
don't care the right-wingers now the
thing they love saying is
we fought a war to separate from europe
from england
why would we care what other countries
think about us now why do we care what
what england thinks about what's going
on here we it doesn't matter we we
fought to get away from them okay
the world looks at what's happening
and they see these piecemeal fringe
discussions and by fringe i mean just
dealing with the fringes the edges of
the debate
well maybe
if you call and you say i think they're
dangerous guys if you're under 25 should
you even be able to buy any kind of
rifles i mean that's one of my one of
the points on my 10 to 12 point proposal
if you're under 25 to get any firearm
shouldn't you need
community letters of support from adults
who say i have no concerns with this
person having a firearm
so again i know that people love to say
well
this one provision wouldn't have done
anything in this particular case
right but if you look at my list which
is i didn't come up with the points
these are points that have been floating
around of 10 to 12 ideas to limit mass
shootings to prevent mass shootings
four five or even six of them could have
directly impacted this particular
shooter having had the knives seized
because people were worried he would
kill everyone should have disqualified
him from legally buying firearms oh but
sir that's not due process guys look at
the situation we have in this country
um under 25 straight up shouldn't even
be able to get some of these types of
weapons
would have had it but so i could go on
these things can make a difference we
haven't even tried them we tried the
assault weapons ban in the 90s and it
did reduce
the number frequency and severity of
mass shootings to some degree now some
will say well was it statistically
significant okay that's one of 10 or 12
provisions that i've put together
we have supposedly i mean listen do we
really believe doors are going to solve
the problem of outdoor parade mass
shootings do we really believe securing
fire escapes is going to solve the issue
of shootings in a movie theater we need
systemic change
very few
of those in positions of power are
willing to really do it talking about
republicans here um and you know we can
keep talking about doors and ceilings
and
walls and windows all we want
uh it's not gonna make a difference big
picture so that's where we are police
knew about him they seized his knives
they were worried he was a danger to
himself and others and then he went and
legally bought guns and did what he did
on monday that's where we are
my audience knows i read i read a ton of
books i read nonfiction i read fiction
at night i'm always trying to consume
information and the truth is i don't
have the time to read every non-fiction
book that i would like to read one thing
i do not have time to add to what i'm
reading in paper form
is more history but i want to know about
history and that's where our sponsor
blinkist comes in blinkist doesn't
replace reading books cover to cover the
way i love to do but for example with
everything going on right now with roe v
wade i wanted more of a detailed history
of roe v wade in the united states so on
blinkist i was able to get a 15-minute
condensed audio book of the mary ziegler
book abortion and the law in america roe
v wade to the present and in 15 minutes
i get a great overview blinkist also has
slide presentations that will take you
about 15 minutes to go through so it's
not to replace reading it's in addition
to for me you get the key takeaways from
blinkist from the books i would
certainly otherwise miss out on you can
try blinkist for free for seven days and
get a 25 discount off of a subscription
at
blinkist.com pacman the link is down
below